I almost
said tut tu tu tu tu tu tu Oh kairi nasai masu I'm moving
today I'm moving, I'm moving and I'm grooving and I'm
smooving Hi Welcome in, welcome in but okay good my thing is
working hello hello thank you guys so much you guys were
we're we're doing it before stream i heard a new group
called mvp is debuting soon well actually actually oh excuse
me hold on um actually the group is called den sent you not
of is the first letters of each member in the group um mint
uh vicky and phoebe yeah mint vicky and phoebe so um
actually the group is called densetsu.exe but i can't
believe that i can i can do this i can't i can't believe i
could just put up my glasses and and fix your and and and
call out your mistakes Vicky's name?
No, I couldn't remember if it was Phoebe or Vicky first.
I was like, is it MPV or
MVP?
That's why.
For real though, congratulations.
Thank you!
Yes, our little group, Our little group will be debuting
this route.
Oh, I forgot to put the video.
I was going to have it on the...
On the...
The starting...
Sooo!
Starting...
Starting Scoooon!
No!
Yo, yo, yo, yo, yo, yo, yo, yo, yo, yo.
Yo, yo, yo, yo, yo, yo, yo, yo, yo, yo, yo.
The dot EXE is important.
Don't forget it.
Exactly.
It's there, too.
starting skewed
ah i was gone for a couple days but i did stream once oh my
gosh i said i was going to stream more than once and i was
so optimistic i i keep doing this i keep doing this where
i'm like oh i could stream i could stream but honestly it
was such a crazy amount of time that i was
I could at least stream once, though.
But it's all good.
It's all good.
We were so busy.
I was.
$110 stream.
No, no, no.
My data plan caps.
It's all good.
Ambition is cute.
I, the thing is, too, is like, I bring my whole travel
setup, which is very heavy.
And I want to, I feel like if I...
I bring it because I want to use it, obviously.
Like, I don't bring it just to carry it.
Like, I want to use it.
And so I become very ambitious.
And even if I can stream once, I feel like that's worth it
more than...
If I can...
You know, if I bring it and stream once, it's more worth it
than...
than not...
than bringing it and not using it at all, obviously.
I missed you when you were gone.
Ah, I missed you guys, too!
It was my birthday a few days ago!
As well as roughly a year since I started watching you!
I wanted to say thank you for being my com-yosey!
That I look forward to the upcoming debut!
Thank you!
Happy birthday, Ben!
Ben Birdland.
Ben, what is it?
Ben Birdland?
Or Ben Birdland?
Ben-Bland.
Ben?
Blah, blah, blah.
Hold on, I'm kidding.
Happy birthday.
Oh,
geez.
Oh, geez.
No.
Thank you for serving me.
I got FNAF 2 Popeyes combo yesterday.
Give me food poisoning.
Wait, J-R.
Wait, my tummy also hurt today.
But I did not have Popeyes.
The cake was super mid, and worst of all, they didn't even
give me any packaging.
into the movie wait that's the worst me to go brr did you
really spend 110 in data because you missed us i i said so
many times that my thing caps at like 80 dollars okay it
caps at 80.
so no i didn't It's been $110.
This is false advertising.
$12.30 though.
Yes!
Taito!
Thank you.
$80 is so much better than $110.
Yeah.
It's okay.
It's all good.
And what's so silly too is the day after.
So basically what had happened is I tried to sign in so
backing up i was at a hotel i was at a i was at a hotel and
you'll have to sign in with your login to get free wi-fi at
the hotel are we following i have an account at said hotel
chain so i went to log in and when i went to log in so i
could get my free wi-fi it said
Hey, there's trouble logging in right now.
We can't log you in.
But now that I think about it, I think the hotel had Wi-Fi
that you could pay for.
And it was like $10.
Wait a second.
But the But it probably would have been so bad It probably
would have been Unstreamable She bit on my rate to like it
Here's another gig Question mark Oh thank you Wait oh gosh
It probably would have been really bad It probably would
have been so bad Like the quality For the why my concert no
i don't bring it up so that you guys will donate though
please thank you for that christopher thank you oh thank you
so much hindsight is 2020 and at a significant discount it
was well i wanted you guys to have the best quality of just
my voice no video
playing in the background.
Do you guys hear that popping?
Or is it my headphones?
I mean, that was my birthday last weekend.
Get a happy birthday from my kamiyoshi.
That's good!
Wait, you do hear it.
What is that?
Weird.
Haunted.
It was like...
It was ASMR.
You don't hear it anymore, though, right?
I don't either.
Is it...
It's .exe because you guys are evil!
Like Sonic Jump.
Every .exe is evil.
So true.
Me, brain smooth and tired today.
Make you make brain good and full of energy.
Brain go, yippee!
Also, milk.
Thank you for the...
Super chat.
Yeah, don't hear it anymore.
I think it's because maybe I was clicked out of the game.
MVP drowned.
Haunted is on brand true.
Now, Miasa would like to buy one megabyte per hour Wi-Fi
access, please.
Did the gummy bear charger come under?
You guys.
You guys might...
They said it would explode.
I'm so sad.
I'm actually so sad.
I wouldn't.
I don't care if it'll explode.
I had a little gummy bear on it.
I don't care.
Too much power.
Arevo Charger exploding is on bread.
I know.
So I think I'll give up.
How sad.
I'm so sad.
I mean...
Where else?
Now, I hope they realize that there's a market for very cute
chargers.
Alright, Anchor.
Get on it, please.
Put gummy bears on your chargers.
I need it right now.
I'll buy five.
I'll do it.
Thank you guys for all the super chats.
Thank you so much.
How?
Minky now has pay per stream?
No!
Oh no, all dot EXEs are evil.
Better delete them from the computer right now!
No, do not do this.
Yeah, do not do that.
Looking forward to MVP debuts?
Thank you!
Can't wait to see you all shining bright, making your dreams
a reality.
Also, I miss you, Vito.
Thank you, Phil!
Thank you so much.
Thank you.
I tried Albany's gummies before.
Not Albany.
Is this a D's joke?
I hope you're having a great day, Vito.
You too.
Almost got the one-year badge.
I got a new job today.
Paul, thank you.
Oh, congratulations.
Pretty good day so far.
Have a good stream.
Have a good day.
Have a better day.
Have the bestest day.
Keep having a good day.
Keep going.
Wait, oh my gosh.
I'm trying to read the super chats that I missed earlier.
But the YouTube sucks.
Sorry.
Okay, I think I got it.
We just turned the game music all the way up.
It's like pretty high right now.
I think it'll, uh, I think right now it's just the ambience,
but it should, it should be up.
How was they cancel my gummy bear charger?
They said it would explode the most mint-fantile thing ever.
Can you ever, wait, have you ever seen the U-green Uno?
It's kind of cute.
I haven't.
Is that a charger?
Is it okay if I name my new kitty after you?
Of course!
What is it gonna be, mean kitty?
Hmm.
Yul Green approve.
I usually get Anchor stuff.
Not the card game.
Hold on, I'm going to look it up like right now.
Yul, Yul Green, Uno.
I've never heard of this brand before.
Wait, that's kind of cute.
That is cute.
It's like a little robot guy.
He's smiling even.
Wait, this is so cute.
He's kind of like...
That's what he's like.
Anchor is pretty solid for all cords and power banks.
Yeah, I feel like they've got a good thing going.
Wow, I'll look into this hue green.
Thank you for the suggestion.
That's cute.
It's been a year so fast.
Wow!
Ghost cutie.
Wait, that's 15 months is more than a year.
Thank you, though.
Yesterday was my birthday.
gonna get a super minky birthday song even though it's a day
like gopy happy birthday happy birthday so many birthdays i
missed i'm sorry i'm sorry i'm sorry i'm sorry i feel this
next uh so i know i was gone for a couple days and then
sunday i'm also starting gone so i for for until december I
feel like I'm missing so much.
For like two weeks even.
I feel though this trip, my upcoming trip is pretty busy.
It was a vacation, a short vacation, and then it suddenly
was just like, oh, you're in Japan?
Do you want to do this work?
And I'm like, I can't say no.
And then they're like, do you want to do this work?
So I apologize in advance.
advance that i got extended because i can't say no but it's
other things that i want to do one of them's really cool i
hope it works out um but uh i feel that this with this
upcoming trip because it's so busy for me i probably will be
streaming like night japan time which is gonna be early
morning for you guys i don't know i'm gonna try and do some
streams i'm gonna try and wake up early Plans are involving
me waking up early and going to do something.
And so I'm like, well, I even have time to stream in the
morning in Japan so that I can then stream at my normal
time.
Some of us are on JST.
Then it'll be perfect for you.
Maybe.
Night Japan is perfect EU.
Sounds great.
Yeah, there you go.
So, hmm.
So, the timing might be a little varied, but I'll do my best
to stream, even if it's morning of EST.
Yes, yes, just giving you guys a heads up since my morning
so far, so busy, it seems right now.
Can't wait for Friday.
Me too!
Actually, I can't wait for Friday.
I still have so much to do.
Isn't a nice surprise this game in Okami were peak video
games or art games for my teenage years.
I played Okami, but I'm surprised.
And I always saw this game.
I don't know why I never played it.
I think maybe I did not have the console.
What was it?
Like PS3?
But I did play Okami.
Yeah, I didn't have PS3.
Hmm.
I didn't get one until I was like, okay.
time to stream and play Metal Gear Solid 4 so yeah this game
kind of fell off my radar and now I get to play it now and
so I'm very very excited I'm very excited hi Mito can you
guess to me with your XOL powers when a boat sailing from
Japan 47 degrees 9 oh what's that mean what's uh hope you
enjoy journey thanks i saw some funny comments kind of
discussing my job that i described in my last in my previous
stream the work stream which is funny because i did no work
but all i did was talk about my old work how funny i hope
you're doing so well was my birthday this past week and may
i ever go to the We'll sing this song for all the birthdays
that I missed over the past couple of days.
Happy birthday.
Congratulations.
Happy birthday with salutations.
Happy birthday.
May your sky stay blue.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday.
Well, yeah.
People's reactions to that were very funny.
Honestly, I guess, yeah, like, there was, you know, I talked
about it, and I described it quite in a funny way.
It was also so long ago that I don't remember every little
tiny aspect of it.
But then people were, like, commenting saying, like, oh, she
probably did something like this.
and I was like oh yeah I do remember doing that so it was it
was yeah it was a job and and the thing too is like we
worked with some major like Japanese manufacturing companies
like the the places that like build the big the big like um
hold on uh like construction um uh construction like
machinery so yeah I had to be I had to be very accurate
thank you Mito smiling so much it hurts right now
Vinto used to bint the boats was interested to hear that in
your last stream.
It was, I've, as someone who is dead, I have the phrase,
lived many lives.
It's quite accurate for me, maybe.
Do you know the other game?
What?
If you want to hear more about that, you can go to my
previous stream.
We're going to play Journey!
Journey, journey, journey.
I'm very excited.
I saw that this one was pretty short, and I, unfortunately,
I have meetings with the other Densitoo Gurleys.
Well, not meetings, but we're meeting up basically every
night this week.
So many, many things that we have to finalize and stuff.
So don't stop believing me, don't think.
Thank you!
So, yeah, busy, busy, busy for sure.
So let's get started then.
Let's start.
Let's go on our journey.
Well, you end up playing with a wisp.
I don't know.
Isn't it like, I don't know really anything about this game,
but I think like you get paired up with someone and it's
random or something.
So excited for your idol debut.
Thank you.
Wow.
I'm playing a PC on Steam, so.
Whoa.
Wow.
Was that me?
Yes.
I'm on controller.
Yeah.
Oh, whoa.
Oh, it's telling me to look around.
Wow!
That's me.
That's telling me to move.
Look at the sand!
Oh, it looks so edible.
Oh, wow.
Wow!
Oh!
What did I do?
What is that?
I could be go!
Go, go, go, go.
Kuala.
QR code.
What?
Oh, whoa.
Heavy.
Look at that.
So cool.
Everyone has always been saying how beautiful and beautiful
this game looks and sounds.
Anakin seething right now.
Yeah, he is.
Wow.
Journey!
Just a small town, girl.
Oh, we're still going.
What are these in the sand, though?
They're not gravestones, are they?
Is that gonna be me?
Hello?
You are called...
Scan my, scan for my mixtape.
Keyblade graveyard.
Oh my gosh.
These definitely...
They have like little symbols on them.
Are they different?
If they're different than their gravestones.
Hmm.
There's some bullets up there.
there.
Get those guys.
Wait.
Can I hop?
Okay, he hops all on his own.
Wait!
Is that my symbol?
No.
Who is it?
I'm calling somebody!
Pick up the phone!
Whoa!
Oh, okay.
I can only do that when these guys replenish my thing.
Well, luckily there's many of them!
Oh, nice.
Nice roll.
Are they the spirits of my ancestors?
Well, I want to go in there, but I feel like I should be
following.
Because...
Thank you.
Because there's this.
I feel like I should be following the path a little bit.
Good night means out.
Good night.
This is Anakin Skywalker's least favorite game.
Truly.
Scan it to use code boomerang ever.
We'll try going here first.
How do I meet somebody?
Who's gonna play with me?
One lucky...
person who's been waiting for someone else to join playing
journey for so many years what is this oh
oh did i do
it does does anything in here match my thing my symbol my QR
code I don't think so.
See the graves?
It was this one that I think looked like it.
Ooh, the sound of the rocks is nice.
Okay, now they tell me to go this way.
Is this game pretty linear?
Please, magic cloth.
I want to fly in.
I wish to fly.
Yeah?
Okay.
More magic cloth!
Thank you!
It looks so cute.
It does look pretty cute, no?
Oh, I did not jump high enough.
Oh geez, okay.
That's fine.
What is this?
Somebody listen to my song!
Why is it glowing?
Only one, too.
Mysterious.
There's a glowing over there, too.
Hmm.
Whoa.
I need to get in there.
You can hold it for a bigger area.
Whoa.
Thank you.
Open up.
Can you get me?
They're trapped.
Oh, there's some trapped in here too!
Oh my gosh.
Give me more.
Please?
I'm hungry.
Thank you.
Oh, they're all trapped.
Interesting.
Happy Day Saturday.
Happy birthday, other wisps too.
Hatata!
Happy birthday!
So many birthdays.
Come on up.
Oh, shoot.
Oh, I'm bad at it.
These guys are skipped.
When do I meet somebody else?
Hello.
Please.
Thank you.
Oh, up here, up here.
Hop, hop, hop, hop.
Hop, hop.
Did we learn a new one?
Whoa!
Okay?
Interesting.
Oh, whoa, whoa.
Oh, I ran out.
My scarf got longer.
That's what happened.
What's going on up here?
Ah!
Whoa!
Need!
Free!
Be free!
Yeah!
Give me more.
Woo-hoo!
Nice!
But there was one...
That one.
I want that one as well.
Hmm.
Before we do that...
We can always...
Stick the landing.
Yes, longer, longer, longer.
Okay.
It still dies so fast, though.
You're a landing.
Yes, they all want to touch my scarf.
So if I do this...
Oh!
Wee!
So awesome.
So what's this going on up here?
Okay.
Oh, oh wait, uh, one more?
One more?
It's so satisfying.
Oh, did we just sit down?
Like a little cat.
Our character does kind of look like a cat, no?
Hello?
It's a light volcano.
Oh.
The character is so cute.
The birds make the crops grow.
It's their poop.
And that makes the people grow.
And then the people get cats.
They build bigger trees.
So we must restore the birds.
so that we can bring back the plants and the people.
That's what we must do.
So smart.
I know.
Do you guys see that?
There's my partner.
Who are you?
They're running away.
She is an archaeologist.
player two I'm guessing I couldn't open the other stuff in
there because I just left hopefully can you make a funny
face like that or like really funny like this
player two where are you the sounds in this game are just so
nice Okay, I see that down there.
Let's go get it.
Someone must be playing it too, right?
Right now?
You can have your chance to...
There they are!
What's happening to me?
Wow!
Oh!
Yes, extend your...
Your scar.
Hi player two!
I've never played this game before, have you?
They said, yes, and how about you?
How are you today?
I'm good, thank you.
Whoa, are you glowing?
Are you a wisp?
Chirp if...
Oh.
Chirp if you're a wisp.
I can't tell
What is this?
Oh, oh, cool
What's happening?
Release them!
Release the birds!
Chirp, three chirps if you're a wisp
One, two, three, four That was four Three, if you're a
wizard.
That's three?
Can't tell.
One, two, three.
That was three!
Nice!
Come on up!
There's also one over there.
What?
I guess we got to keep making them...
Wait.
Oh.
Uh-oh.
This is me laughing at you.
Ha.
Oh.
There's one over there.
Wait, do I need...
There we go.
More birds.
There's this one too.
This one looks like it'll connect.
Yeah?
You need help?
Whoa, what's happening?
I'm releasing birds.
I can't count the three.
It's definitely one of us.
Don't be mean.
What's up?
Yeah?
What's wrong?
This guy?
Oh, you released it.
Hold on, there was a big one.
There's actually so many here.
There's that big guy.
But I also want to extend my...
I want to extend my thing.
My scarf.
Am I going to be going crazy with exploring?
This is part of the journey, no?
You can...
Can I even extend those with the beeps too?
Oh, you can!
This way over here, yeah, yeah!
Let me know also if the music gets a little too loud.
I know you guys say loud, or we'll say louder or something,
but...
Mintota!
Good morning!
Me too, me too!
Nice.
Wait, there's still sparkle.
What's this sparkle for?
Hmm.
Mysterious.
Wait, so if I...
Whoa!
Cool!
Maybe just to let you know it was there.
Maybe.
Ayya!
Whoa,
whoa, whoa!
Nice!
Yeah, I was gonna say this will make a big guy.
Supposed to get the little pieces, too.
Little pieces?
The thing, the glowy bits?
I feel like you have to, so you can extend your...
Oh!
So you can extend your scarf.
Oh, I think that...
Did it know?
But there's still more to see.
Partner, we're not leaving yet.
I'm the leader of this coup.
Not yet.
We must get more birds.
Pronto.
Eyebow.
The journey for the longer scarf.
The longest scarf.
The top chicken.
Yeah, we're birds, and we're birding it up.
Oh, get up there.
Get up there.
Wait.
There we go.
Wait, there's something behind there!
Aibo!
Aibo, look!
Oh!
Aibo, Aibo!
It's lore!
It's lore, look!
What is that?
Cities, they are.
had cities even.
They were an advanced society.
Can you fill me up?
Thank you.
Okay.
Um.
There's... Oh, that one didn't open anything.
That, I can see it's open.
Um...
We have to get up there.
I think the best way to get that...
Maybe from here?
We'll make it.
Or if we go from the top.
I think From here, we can make it, though.
Oh, my God.
Ah, nice.
She's too good.
Use the boards.
Oh, I forgot.
It's fine.
We didn't need them.
Settling in with some homemade curry.
Ah, Choki!
Miss Consanity.
Thank you.
If I died and came back as a flying dish towel in the
desert, I'd be pretty mad.
Why?
I think it'd be quite relaxing.
No?
Just me?
Listen to the song of my people!
Hey!
Top me off!
Thank you?
Wait, they did not top me off!
Chatty over here!
Here we go!
Do we get everything in here, you think?
I don't think I see anything else.
Yeah, I did?
Okay, glue.
Should be.
Cool!
Okay, I get this side.
Eyeball.
Good job!
Oh.
We have to sit.
Oh my gosh, they really look like cats.
Yes?
The great cat.
Oh my god.
Wait, it's kind of freaky.
Wait, that looks like a bird.
That's a bird.
War.
Then they got cats.
They built big towns.
Wait, that looks like the thing we just kind of made, right?
And trains!
They were so advanced!
It's a big bird!
And electricity!
Is it because of the scarves?
The little birds?
The fabric birds?
Beep, beep, beep, beep.
They use the cloth for power.
Glad you're home and happy exploring, Possum!
Thank you.
Hope to be back for the end.
Thank you!
It's my birthday today.
Oh my gosh, King of Tendies, happy birthday!
It's round of love for Mickey and Whisper that I've been
here.
Well, I've been here.
Happy birthday!
Wow.
There's something...
There's like a shooting star above the...
Above the...
The volcano.
It's pink!
I'll release you.
What's that sound?
though.
Whoa!
Different type of bird.
Oh my gosh.
Cool!
No item name.
Thank you so much, brother.
That's why I got to thank you.
I took Peter's... I was like looking at your name like, how
do I say this?
How do I say this?
What's over here?
He's calling too.
He wants us to fall, though.
Oh.
Thank you.
They're so nice.
Oh.
Goodbye.
Where are
we going?
We're just following him.
Am I playing with a viewer or a rando?
We think it's a viewer, no?
Do a little chirp if you're a viewer.
I feel like that was too early.
See?
Oh, he wants his friend.
Release the friend.
I don't think randomly people are playing this game in 2025.
I think that's the same.
Wow!
I have my own magic card.
Oh, oops.
Sorry.
Wait, can I get back on?
Wait.
Oh, don't move.
Don't move.
Wait, don't move.
Wait, oh shoot.
Can somebody grab me?
Wait.
Can somebody pick me up?
Please.
Can you pick me up?
No.
No!
I thought I could move.
My magic carpet.
What's in here?
Cats.
Mew, Mew, Mew, Mew, Mew, Mew, Mew, Mew, Mew, Mew, Mew, Mew
Mew, Mew, Mew, Mew, Mew, Mew, Mew, Mew, Mew, Mew, Mew, Mew,
Mew, Mew, Mew, Mew, Mew, Mew, Mew, Mew, Mew, Mew, Mew.
You were so close, you were glowing!
to be...
Yeah.
Oh, we're going this way?
Okay, no biggie.
Pick me up.
Pick me up, please.
Come on, come on.
We're both struggling, me and my partner.
It's a sound.
It's so loud.
Come on.
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
Come here, hold on, birds.
Hold on.
Birds!
Yes.
Oh, I think I got it.
Nice.
What do you do when Minto leaves?
Wait for her to get back.
I'm back!
I'm back for a few days.
Minto flying around like a grain of sand.
Please, pick...
Please, upies!
Please, upies, please!
I guess we can constantly be jumping, though, because
they'll give us...
Constant, like...
They'll constantly be refreshing our...
Where are they going?
Our scarf.
Oh, this way.
No, no ABJ.
Unless it's A, B, J.
No, sorry, wait.
Oh, whoa, whoa, whoa.
We're lagging.
Whoa, we're lagging.
A.
A, B.
Dot, dot, dot, dot, dot, dot, dot, dot.
J.
You get it?
What are we talking about?
Always be jumping.
It can be abbreviated.
You just have to be careful about it, you know?
What are you doing?
I hear noise, but I don't know where it's from.
Where's my partner?
Friend?
Oh, oh, they want this guy out.
I see.
I see, I see.
Don't worry, I got him.
Oh, you can't.
You got him.
Good job.
What do they want now?
Oh wait, can we go inside?
No.
Where do they go?
What do they want now?
This away.
Time to leave.
Always be journeying.
Yeah!
Oh my gosh, I'm flying so much!
Give me!
Or don't.
Okay, thank you.
I wish you could jump, jump though.
If I have- you can't jump if you have no- You know?
We'll let them free!
Oh, there's a thing!
I see it!
I see it, I see it, thank you.
Good job.
They build mechs!
Wow.
They build mechs, too.
Metal gear?
Where are we going?
Gosh, this game is so pretty.
This is where we came from, no?
Cloth gear.
Look how shiny.
the sand is and everything is
there an achievement for singing so many times I'm gonna
journey after week oh after after work after work for one
dollar tacos yeah am I am I going the right way scarves yeah
okay my partner just said yes that's right wish Metal Gear
get nominated at TGA I did it not I actually I have I never
I never know when these things are happening this looks kind
of spooky wait where are they taking us um scarves are we
going the right way wait why am I lagging so bad I changed I
thought this game wouldn't be very heavy so I changed the
graphics to high.
They were like automatically put at medium but now I'm
nervous.
Could be the network.
That's what I'm thinking.
It's like that kind of lag you know.
Did they go up?
Where are they going?
Seems to be the case.
Around here?
Or something?
Can that Oh, gosh, I'm stuck.
Um, thank you.
Thank you.
Oh.
Something's...
Oh, he's got me.
Thank you!
Oh, wait.
Is that a bad guy, or...
Oh, it's like a machine.
Whoa.
A little bit spoopy now.
You okay?
Don't fall.
Whoa, it's making me.
Oh, it's freaky.
Whoa.
There's so many trapped in there.
We'll set you free.
Right over here.
Are you gonna help us up?
Help me up.
Thank you.
Let's go, eyeball.
Hi, me.
Hello!
Did
I do it?
Did we get it?
Yeah.
My wife missed you!
We're both very excited about density.exe.
Also, the Minto Pansu didn't fit one of...
I see.
Scarfens.
They're scarfing it down.
...
Yeah, we want to do lots of covers together.
Oh, more.
Bigger cities.
More, taller.
Wait, are these all like power?
Basically, they're not houses, they're like...
Energy, they're like...
Energy centers, kind of.
Whoa, or maybe?
Be free!
They do kind of remind me of like, yeah, like dolphins or
whales or something.
Power plants!
Yeah, that's the word that I was thinking of.
They're waiting for us, eyeball.
There's two that are waiting for us.
Whoa.
Wow!
Pink.
I'm zooming.
Watch this sick flip.
Whoa, dang it, I dropped too.
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait,
wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Yes.
Wee!
She's gaming.
I'll land right.
Did something.
Oh, released more.
Good job!
What else we got going on?
Is this a thing?
This looks like a thing.
Good job!
Good job, Ibu!
Wait, there's like some guys over here.
You could see me in the corner leaving, this cousin?
Yay!
Okay, hold on, there were guys over here.
Now that I know that there's sometimes like secrets, it
makes me wonder, you know?
What could be up here?
Aha!
And the Sedge.
More lore!
Hey, Aibol.
They're just more cats in cities.
Cats in boxes.
So now we got...
Do you see that up there?
Aibol!
Aibol, there's another thing!
She said, yes, I do.
I do see it.
Great dominto, sama.
I'm having cheesecake for Thanksgiving.
Can't decide what flavor.
Oreo?
Oreo.
Wait, how do we get up there?
Here?
Right here?
Okay.
I'm watching you.
Ah, go get it!
Go get your dreams!
Wait, am I
gonna make it?
Wait, eyeball.
Eyeball, I don't know if I'm gonna make it.
Eyeball!
I made it.
Just kidding.
I made it!
I'm guessing that probably was...
Oh my gosh, it's so smoky.
That probably was like the only secret in this area.
We got everything else, I think.
So we can continue onwards.
You ready?
Oh,
I flew hard.
I flew like...
Eyeball!
Eyeball, I kept...
I couldn't stop!
Oh my gosh, we're still going.
Let's go.
you think you'd want an actual churro if i actually like
cinnamon cheesecake sounds pretty good i'm not gonna lie i
don't know but i'm such an oreo fan of anything oreo drink
i don't want to miss the secrets whoa whoa okay down here Oh
shoot
I already missed a secret Oh well It's my first time playing
I'm gonna miss secrets
You missed it but it's okay My bad I tried I tried looking
Oh my god it's so orange It reminds me of a tangerine drink
Oh Wow!
Oh my gosh, cinema!
Wow!
Whoa!
Oh, I almost ran into the wall.
It's so pretty.
I'm going?
We're still going?
I can't see anything.
It's so orange.
Oops, I'm orange.
Up there maybe is something if I can even... I don't even
know.
if i could reach that maybe from like over here i don't
think so they forced me back
who's calling whoa
we have breaking bad up in here
okay i know the sand looks so soft but i'm sure this is hard
are you okay
are you okay okay good before we do that there's some stuff
I want to explore like what's this over here anything it
might be nothing it could be something it is something good
job team I got a spam call when you said that what is going
on there do you Get it, eyeball?
Whoa, mouth!
I'll follow you.
Is there anything over there?
I don't know if there is anything here.
No.
The people divided the cities, maybe.
to imagine all of this was such lush green you know all
right ready eyeball good job yeah good job good job it was
basically timed perfectly
what happened to them we don't know it's part of the journey
to find out look how long my scarf is now basically a cape
No!
The power, the electricity!
Severed!
The machinery!
What happened to it?
Uh-oh.
Wait, that doesn't...
Wait, this seems really bad.
Wait, this does not seem good.
War.
Oh no!
They fought over it.
No!
Let's go, Eibor.
Into the abyss.
I want to hear Mint say the phrase.
War.
War has changed.
That?
Wow.
The sand is so shiny.
Look at the kick up more sand.
New day.
Kick it up.
Kick up...
Kick up the sand.
Yeah, kick up that sand.
Porker is cooking now to watch OC.
Yummy!
What are these?
These look special.
Just a rack.
Oh, okay.
Oh, there are some...
scarf dolphins down here.
Oh!
It looks like we're at the bottom of the ocean, no?
Whoa!
Are these the trains?
They look like it now, right?
Is there anything in here?
You check out that one, I boy.
Check out this one.
Call if you need help.
Oh!
In here!
In here, in here!
Get your thing.
You're welcome.
I don't know what they were saying.
I don't really understand their accent.
Thank you.
Mint.
That's what they said.
Whoa, wow!
Okay, so it's meant to look like the bottom of the ocean.
Because look at that.
Wow!
Whoa.
Whoa!
Wait.
There's one in here.
Now you are Kelp.
Jeffrey, hi!
Yep.
I got it too.
Wait, is there one down here?
Is that one?
No.
My eyes do deceive me.
Kelp.
Minto is cute.
I want to know who's playing with me.
I want to see them in chat.
Is it?
Where are you?
Wait, oh, I don't think I'll make it.
Oh, oh.
Oh, wait.
It did help, actually.
Wait.
This the way?
Oh, there's my abbo.
You were in the calp.
What are you doing in there?
They will show their name after the credits.
Really?
Wait, are you still in here?
Oh, you're gone.
Hello.
Unless you were talking in chat.
Hold on, I'm making sure there's nothing in there.
Jellies.
Jellies!
Jelly, jelly, jelly.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
There's one up here.
Nice.
Good job to him.
Wow.
It's so beautiful.
It's so pretty, it makes me mad.
Oh, there's nothing up here, I think.
On this?
No, it doesn't seem like it.
Oh.
We're going down!
Oh!
Ouch.
You see anything over here?
No, it doesn't look like it.
Sorry, Eye Boy.
I love exploring too much.
It's okay, Minto!
That's what they said.
Nothing here.
This is spooky.
This is quite spooky.
Are there bosses in this game?
How do you even fight?
Yeah?
Oh my gosh.
Um, okay, I spoke.
Did I die?
You know?
So loud.
Ah!
That spooked a heckie out of me.
Okay, did we keep going?
It was so loud.
Watch out for those.
I think
you lost Scarf.
Did I?
No.
They damage your scarf permanently.
Uh-oh.
Wait, is this a stealth mission?
Oh my gosh.
Eyebo, I'm scared.
Eyebo, Eyebo, I'm scared.
Hey, we were going after that.
Is this now a sneaking mission?
Oh my gosh.
Oh my god, the music is all scary all of a sudden.
Eyebo!
I'm scared!
We should get higher up ground?
So that if we need to slide, we can slide.
You see my vision?
Wait, did we get up here?
Or anything?
And my scarf looks so short now, so sad.
Oh my god.
He's scanning.
Ah!
Sorry.
Oh my god, this is...
That's an alive one!
Good to know.
Oh my gosh.
Eyeball, I'm scared.
Eyeball, I didn't know this was going to be a horror game.
Eyeball.
Eyeball, I'm scared.
What if we die?
Okay.
That's one.
But now there's one.
two of them and there's the second one above us oh my god
get under here don't don't don't how do we get out of this
mess all big metal gear reference i got scared while riding
to super
he's circling yeah he's spawn camping how do we get out of
here you take the lead eyeball oh Don't take the lead, Aibo.
Aibo, take the wheel!
I'll follow you.
I think this one's also gonna come alive though, no?
So yeah, I'll run up here.
It's gonna be loud!
Aibo!
I'm gonna turn it down just a tad more for me.
Okay.
Alright, we're good.
There's one over there, isn't there?
I see it, I see it.
Nice.
Such a good eyeball, yeah.
I saw him with his eye, but I don't...
Oh, I see orange over there.
Okay.
Like I saw, I had seen a blue light, you know.
Oh my gosh, wait.
This one's gonna come alive, isn't it?
No?
It's not?
Okay.
Now I don't know who to trust.
Oh, here we go.
I guess if you move in front of them more of them more of
them wake up or something oh my gosh oh my gosh oh my gosh
there we go you can trust me me though yeah i can oh my gosh
oh my gosh will he come up here no no yes no i see something
down there
Okay, follow my lead.
Wait, I think I've messed up.
Oh my gosh.
Eiffel!
What the heck just happened?
Where am I?
Okay.
I think they just said, see, I told you.
We were- That was scary.
Bird person.
Oh my gosh, is that why the mountain is split?
Oh, they're all dead!
Oh, my- or asleep.
One or the other.
Mountains and mountains of graves.
It looks nighttime.
It could be that they're not, they're, you know, they sleep
at night.
Oh, they become stars in the sky!
Oh!
Me!
Sleeping under the sand.
They're hibernating.
Let's go, Aibo.
Good job, by the way.
So are we like protected in here?
Can we leave?
Whoa.
The gravestones.
So these were gravestones.
full of sand and whimsy
oh sneak through the underground passage without tearing
your scarf wait i got an achievement so wait maybe i didn't
lose any of my scarf yippee
so i did it okay no hit run if you heard that that was my
phone I kicked off my chair.
Oopsie.
What's this?
It's my stage.
Clumsy Ghost Breaks phone.
No, I have a screen protector on, but it's gotten a little
bumpy.
It's gotten a little yeah.
It's yeah.
Um, it has, it doesn't have cracks in it, but it has indents
in there for sure.
What is it?
What happened?
Me!
And the graves.
Whoa!
And me!
Now we can just jump as...
Whoa!
Interesting.
What do you see?
I see it!
Oh, oops.
I fell in the water.
Thank you!
Is there anything...
Let's go to this one.
In here, maybe?
If I...
If I yell really loud?
Okay, nothing happens.
Oh, over there.
Maybe.
Okay.
Hold on, I'm gonna replenish here.
Thank you.
Good job, Ibu.
There's eyes!
That's eyes!
The water.
The jellyfish!
Oh, oh, the critters.
I kept saying birds, but they're fish.
I called them birds.
But they're fish.
They're all little fish.
Look at these, even these guys, they're not tiny cloth
birds.
They're fish.
Wait, was anything in here?
Oh, it's so beautiful.
They evolved or devolved, depending.
We're going high, we're going up.
Oh, no, no, no, no!
Where are you?
Where is it?
Where are you, Aibu?
Over there.
Oh gosh.
Eh.
Oh, oh, I see you.
Thank you.
I'm blind.
Good eyeball.
Thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you, thank
you, thank you.
Okay.
Where are you going?
I'm going up.
We're going up.
Oh, help me.
I made it somehow.
Oh, good job.
Hello.
Where do we go from here?
I'm trying to find...
Oh, up there, up there.
Nice.
Follow the scarf animal.
That's us.
Oh, that's me.
I'm blocking the cutscene.
Whoa, whoa, big animal!
Good thing they're friends.
Oh my god.
Whoa.
Wait, what's down there?
Did we already...
Oh, these are the things that we already did.
I'm coming.
I'll get in there.
Oh gosh.
good?
Oh, I'm good.
I'm fine.
So cool.
Gosh, our scarves are going to be so long.
Where'd that guy go?
Yeah, those are the things that we already unlocked.
Come on, buddy.
Did you make it?
Yeah?
Okay.
We made some stairs.
There it is!
Our stairs!
What do you see?
Over here?
What?
Oh, there's another one!
No, we already did this one, though.
Yeah, how are they able to know that we're doing this stuff?
Do they see the future?
I'm not sure.
I like how we float every time we get on these.
It's cool.
Yes, more, more.
Mine and craft.
The prophecy.
Yeah, that would make sense, huh?
Oh.
Wow.
I love the fish.
I want Scarfish.
Okay.
Do it.
And then we go downstairs and there's fireworks!
Is it going to keep rising?
I love energy water.
This is how you feel drinking five...
Wait.
That's the gum.
Did we see all the...
Did we see the...
Oh, they're...
They're all like lighting up here.
Oh, see?
See?
Like that?
Cool!
Me when I drink five gum.
I don't know how many pieces of gum are in my tummy.
Hopefully not so many.
Apparently swallowing gum isn't bad.
Mama!
Yes, I did this!
I did this!
This is my journey!
I crossed the deserts and I made the bridges and I hopped.
And I saw the buildings.
And I ran down the stairs.
I went underground.
And I...
That was scary.
I don't want to go back there.
Oh, now we're going to crawl.
We're going to crawl through the wind.
Up to the top, top, tippy-top mountain.
You and Ible.
Yeah.
There was at least one roll of bubble tape in my belly.
We gotta crawl, we gotta crawl!
We can reach the lips of the mountain and give it a big ol'
smooch.
Crawling in my crawl.
Celeste time?
Oh geez.
Suddenly it turned into a seven hour stream.
Let's go eyeball.
Are you ready to crawl?
Yes or no?
They said, yes, I'm ready to crawl, Minto.
That's what they said.
Is there anything up here?
Am I being two?
The snow!
I thought I had a dirty mind and then he said the same
thing.
Dirty!
Is kissing dirty?
Her song has changed once again.
Oh, thank you!
Oh, wow, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah,
blah.
Do these activate?
Oh, they do!
It's so snowy here.
Oh, there's red guys too.
Wait, is that a bad guy?
He's nice now, right?
Yes?
Why does this game feel almost like playing Peek?
You go through all the different areas and...
Oh, we're crawling.
Oh, yeah.
Okay, nice.
Successfully crawled.
Okay, all right.
Oh, no!
Ah!
Don't fly, Aibo!
Don't fly!
Ah!
Aibo, don't fly.
I think you have to wait behind a rock when it comes, right?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I was just thinking the same thing.
Oh, don't kick me out, though.
Gosh.
Why is the sand or the snow rumbling like that?
Let's get over to the next one.
The sky right here.
I think it can take cover behind the pillars.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
It's not like Titanic where only one person can...
Can get under there, you know?
Or on top of there, I guess.
Run, run, run!
I will be careful.
Don't be Rose, I will.
I'll never let go!
Can we just go through?
You think?
Yeah.
Oh no, now they're tinier.
Unless?
You are so chatty.
What's going on?
I'll never let go of Jack.
Let's go.
Wait.
Oh, that's a plant.
Are you okay?
Are you cold?
Yeah, it's so cold up here.
Don't worry.
Okay.
My...
My controller is like buzzing like crazy.
If you like Journey, you might...
Ooh, what was that?
You might like the game...
Ju-san.
It seems like you're like Journey, but Journey into...
Buzz Buzz 18, but...
Thank you!
Oh, no bad guy!
Why doesn't he like us?
Oh, you have to, like, keep doing this, or else your scarf
will freeze over.
Whoa, whoa, whoa.
I think we're having some connection issues once again.
Oh, my gosh.
Really struggling here.
It's Journey, but Celeste.
Oh, I see.
I see, I see.
Come on.
Keep going.
We're gonna make it.
I'm gonna make it eyeball!
What's in here real quick?
Maybe we could warm this place up a little bit.
Place Celeste?
Honestly, I want to, but I know it's so difficult.
Yeah!
The birds are back!
The sun is shining!
Oh wait, is there anything up here?
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, uh-huh.
If there are birds, there is a secret.
Look at them staring at each other.
Wow.
Romeo and Juliet.
Celeste is not really that hard.
I've heard it's pretty difficult.
But I guess if you're good at platformers, then, you know,
it would be.
It would be a breeze.
I'm not super used to platformers, personally.
Personally, but...
You ready?
Wait, there's more?
Didn't look like it.
No?
Okay.
Alright, onwards.
Nice and refreshed.
Nice and warm.
My toes are toasty.
Requires fast reaction.
Celeste does.
I see, I see.
Defrost!
I'm gonna go on it.
Okay.
Huddle for warmth.
Should we take our clothes off?
so it's skin-to-skin contact that'll probably be the most
effective way you know I learned that and love Hina
um are we in trouble eyeball eyeball don't fly
eyeball are we in trouble
oh why is your scarf my scarf doesn't it doesn't freeze up
so quickly like yours does.
Maybe it does.
Oh my gosh.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, how did I get on top?
I did not mean to do that.
Do you even have skin under the cloth at this game?
Oh, in this game, I thought you meant like, I was going to
be like, well, you know, I'm all ectoplasm, but I guess it
might feel like skin a little Oh my gosh.
Is that me?
Oh, my head's poking out.
I think we can make it.
I can't make it!
I made it.
I'm not gonna make it.
Scarf and Mito slippers stays on.
Look at back, Mito.
Thank you.
Where'd he go?
Oh, where is he?
To the next thing.
What's that over there?
This guy's a pain in my butt.
Do do
do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do.
It didn't open anything.
Wait, I'm scared.
Okay, there he is.
Okay, I think we just got to go for it, eyeball.
Do we go over there?
Ah!
My scarf is running so low!
Ah, warmth.
Are we, uh, I think we're okay, maybe?
He's not actively searching, I think we're okay.
What is that over there though?
Aibo, I want to go!
Oh my gosh, oh my gosh, wait, uh, oh shoot.
Aibo, I'm scared.
Aibo, Aibo, did we go the other way?
Aibo, Aibo, Aibo, Aibo!
Aibo!
Secret is that way.
Oh, I see.
Should we try?
Are
we going to get caught?
Yay!
Secrets are worth it?
Aibo!
Aibo, let's go to the secret!
I want to see it!
Yeah,
yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah!
What is this?
Keep going.
Aibo!
We're both screaming together Push, push, push, push, push,
push, push, push.
Yes, nice.
Wait, it even has a second exit, so that's good.
Hello?
Wow!
Cave.
They all went to the mountain.
They went to the mountain.
What could be there?
Like a pilgrimage.
Like a journey.
When I think, when I'm back, either when I'm back from Japan
or in Japan, I think I'm going to play Myst.
I wanted to honestly play it this week, but I only picked
games that I could, like, beat in one sitting.
So that I wasn't having anything.
Oops, oops.
Having anything that I didn't already have finished.
before I left, you know.
Where is that guy?
Oh, there he is.
Oh, I don't think he's active.
Oh, I was going to say I don't think he's actively
searching.
But he might be now.
Oh!
Maybe we're okay.
Hello, we're okay.
I'm scared.
Don't know anything about Mist myself.
I only remember attempting to play it as a wee ghost.
And...
um failing
we are going the right way still though right
the music is so intense
there's a i don't think he's searching actively right now oh
yeah let's go to this one over here oh god uh oh uh oh uh oh
eyeball Eyeball!
Eyeball?
How did he see you?
I guess he is active.
How did he... How did that...
Ah!
Holy...
Cow!
What the heck just happened?
Eyeball!
Eyeball, don't die on me!
Where are you?
Oh, you're right next to me, okay.
Oh my god, oh my god, oh my god, oh my god, oh my god, oh my
god, oh my god, oh my god, oh my god, oh my god, oh my god,
oh my god, oh no, oh no, oh no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no,
no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, make
a break for it, I think we have to, well, let's try to, and
get to this one?
Maybe?
Running, running, running, running, running, running,
running, running.
Inside, inside, inside.
Okay.
Aibu!
Alright.
Jurassic Park theme would also fit this moment.
Go!
Aibu!
I watched the new Jurassic world.
collatuses in it.
I was very happy about that.
But, well, I didn't dislike it.
I thought it was fine still.
What is it?
Rebirth or?
I thought it was fine.
The gravestones.
Surprise I made another one.
I only watched it because Chris Pratt was not in it.
I watched it because he wasn't in it.
It's now like they're like mutant...
Mutant, uh...
Dinosaur or something?
Whoa.
As soon as we defrost them, they freeze back up.
No, defrost!
Defrost!
stuff the music oh it's so beautiful is there i'm assuming
is there stuff down here is there secret stuff hold on let
me check let me look around i feel like there's probably
something in there no nothing okay thank you guys
Nothing important at this point.
Okay.
Come on, Aibo!
Why do you hate the guy who's gonna play you in the Phantom
Movie?
Don't say it!
Everybody knows Jack Black will play me.
Ooh, breezy!
Watch out!
Don't get swept away now.
Anything over here?
No.
You don't have to follow me, Aibo.
I'm just looking.
Wee!
Hold your ground!
Stay strong!
Hold your ground, hold your ground.
Oh my gosh.
Oh my gosh!
Hold your ground.
Run, run, run, run.
Run, run, run, run!
Ah!
Ow!
I fall!
Hold!
Maybe we can make it to the next ledge.
Over here.
Oh go go go go go nice nice nice.
Nice.
Uh-oh.
Yeah, we're fine, we're fine.
We're fine.
We're not fine.
Everything's bad.
Hang right!
Hang right.
Okay go go go go Go go go go go go go go go go go go go go
go go go go go!
Okay maybe?
Oh my gosh there's like oh my gosh wait this is evil Ah!
Hi boo, hi boo!
I feel like that has to happen Maybe?
Ah Oh, I went into the snow.
Oh.
Wait, where are we?
Oh, okay.
Yeah, our scarf is so small now.
What happened to it?
Does it keep getting blown away?
Oh, whoa.
Oh, my gosh.
Just go.
I will go.
Go.
It's cold.
It keeps breaking off.
Is that what?
Oh my gosh, our scarves are so small now.
Oh, no, no, we have to make it.
And there's a bad guy.
Oh my gosh, big baddie.
Oh, I can
do a sing.
Push, push, push.
The mountain looks so far away, though.
The peak looks so far away.
Oh my gosh.
Huddle close, huddle close.
Oh my gosh, there's so many...
How did they put the gravestones up here?
We've come so far.
We can't freeze over now.
We can't.
We're slow.
We're getting slower, I think.
No, no, no, no, we're getting slower.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
No, no, no, just keep...
I'm pushing as hard as I can.
You can't even hear my voice anymore!
Bump, bump, bump, bump, bump, bump, bump.
Oh my gosh, we're almost there.
Wait, the top of the mountain is gone.
Are we here?
Wait, where are we?
Oh my god, no.
This is like actually going up to Everest.
We gotta start taking our clothes off.
No!
No, don't stop.
Don't stop moving, Eibol.
Sorry, my head is blocking Eibol.
Boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom,
boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom.
Is that my ancestors question mark?
They're judging me.
They say even you failed.
You were supposed to be the prophesized one.
Save me, bird woman.
Oh!
Yes!
We got Super Saiyan!
Oh my gosh.
Okay.
Avoid those guys.
Ah!
And even further beyond!
Aibor!
Is that you?
Eyeball, look.
Eyeball, it's so beautiful.
Well, now here.
Inside?
Okay.
Wee!
Are you
behind me?
Whoa!
Mito just too fast.
My bad.
Hi Boa, we're here together.
We're here together.
I'm zooming.
If I'm missing stuff, sorry.
I'm just having too much fun.
No secrets here?
Okay!
Thank you!
I should go first.
they're up, but I don't know how to move.
Wait, I'm stuck.
Wait.
I messed up.
There we go.
Where's my eyeball?
Oh, there you are.
Aw, did you wait for me?
Much better eyeball than me.
I'm gonna kiss them.
Those sweet, sweet thighs!
wow it's so beautiful it's so beautiful
oh you can't hear my voice anymore.
I'm trying to talk to you, Eibu.
Can you hear me?
Wait, our scarf is once again gone.
Don't get so close to me.
Eibu.
Keep your distance.
Oh, don't get caught on the rocks.
silly
You could still see me trying to talk to him No eye in this
eyeball We're going into the lie we're going into the lie
There they go There they go there we go
Look at us with just two little triangles.
I can't tell if I still see us or if that's a speck on my
monitor.
It's a speck on my monitor.
Oh my god, it's happening.
Oh my god.
Thank you for playing Journey.
Wow!
Who's that?
It's going inside.
Where?
All the places we passed.
Our journey, our journey.
We didn't really travel so far, huh?
Sometimes the journey is harsh and bleak, but all you can do
is keep going.
And the whole thing that- and it's the whole thing that
makes you you yeah Thank you Murphy
As someone that like really enjoys the travel part of Of
like traveling You know, not always just the destination
part.
You know, I appreciate all sorts of journeys.
All throughout life and afterlife.
I don't think they warned people there'd be co-op.
Oh, really?
Yeah, the gameplay and aesthetics are very satisfying.
That's very true.
Oh.
so pretty oh my gosh oh my gosh so pretty life before death
journey before destination
now we have to see Ibo's name when will it show wait hold on
I have to grab my phone I have to make sure that I'm not
missing anything real quick.
Sorry, hold on.
Okay.
It got even more beautiful.
No, I'm super mad.
Aybo, don't go, aren't we the star together?
Oh, there it is.
Oh!
Companions met along the way.
What a reveal!
Thank you, Cash Money Robot!
I've never only seen one companion before.
What do you mean?
Is that about how many times you've played?
Because this is my first time playing.
Legendary way to end.
My starting one left.
Oh!
Oh wait, I did get some achievements.
Let me see what they were.
Library.
Journey.
I unlocked.
Reaching the summit with a companion and return to the
beginning.
Finish the game and return to the beginning.
Oh wait, so if you don't even have your companion, I guess
if they die, right?
It was Cash Money Robot, they said so earlier.
Truly the deep emotional, spiritual connection we formed on
this journey with Cash Money Robot.
That was the best reveal.
Ah!
Thank you for being my eyeball.
That was such a good reveal.
The way it like so slowly.
faded in.
Let's see.
Finish the game with the same partner for the majority of
the journey and return to the beginning.
Only 14% of players have that achievement.
Wow.
Well, thank you, Cashman, you robot, for for what's the
word?
For being my companion and finishing the game with me.
I really appreciate it.
Let's see.
I'm looking at some of the locked achievements.
Start the journey again after a week-long break, okay?
It's like cookie clicker.
Find the hidden desert flower.
Oh, interesting.
Discover all cloth creatures in the desert.
Oh, we didn't find all of them, interesting.
Meet 10 or more unique travelers.
Sit and meditate with another player for more than 20
seconds.
How do you sit?
Maybe if I, like, stop moving, it's an idle animation.
Find a mysterious creature hidden in the temple.
Collect all unique glowing symbols across one or more
journeys.
Cross the broken bridge without completely rebuilding it.
Ooh, cool.
Uncover all 10 ancient glyphs.
Dang it.
Pass through 15 gates while surfing through the sunken city.
You just go AFK.
Ah, okay, okay.
You did a lot of stuff for yourself.
No, these are not the things that I did.
These are the locked ones.
These are the ones that you can still get.
I only got four achievements.
Which was...
A sneak through the underground passage without tearing your
scarf.
Finish the game and return to the beginning.
Reach the summit with a companion and return to the
beginning.
And finish the game with the same partner for the majority
of the journey.
And return to the beginning.
Yeah.
You can get those outside the map in the sunken zone.
city.
Like, you know what?
Pretty nice game to replay, too.
It seems like it, right?
If you get all scarf upgrades, you unlock white robes.
Really?
Oh, cool.
I do want to maybe play again.
Maybe one day, like, a member stream or something, and
somebody can help me get through.
We can play more together, like, more games together.
And maybe, like, different people can help me get different
things or something like that.
Hmm.
So pretty.
Wee!
So pretty!
Oh my gosh.
Wee!
Ha ha ha!
Still need to get an Ocelot skin from Foxhunt.
I know.
The game matches you with a different companion whenever you
change map.
The magic is that you don't know it.
It's rare to make a journey with only one partner, but with
less online players.
Oh!
I see!
So first playthrough, you only match with first players,
which makes the population the match smaller.
Wow!
Oh my gosh!
Also, thank you so much for the Aka doing a...
Aka super, thank you!
Oh, wow!
Wait, so like, if someone else were trying to play...
And...
Like...
Wow, so the fact that we...
That it was me and Cash Money Robot the whole time is, like,
super rare.
Rare?
That's crazy!
Wait, that's so cool, though.
At the same time.
Wowee.
It will only swap if you get too far away from each other.
Because online is low, probably.
Yeah, probably nowadays it's pretty easy to get that
achievement, I'd say.
If, well...
Hmm?
Maybe.
Oh, I'm looking at like some of the other achievements.
The Ancestors One.
Find a mysterious creature hidden in the temple.
Only 8% of players.
Collect all unique glowing symbols across one or more
journeys.
8%!
Back in the day, there was a dedicated community of white
cloak players that would guide people through the game and
help them find all the secrets.
That's so sweet!
That's so cute.
Well, guys, thank you.
Well, that's another game off the list, I suppose.
Another completion.
Let me add it to my...
To my...
You're a super...
Try Princess!
Thank you!
Also, Daily Dio, I'm so sorry.
I think I missed your don't know earlier.
It's one of my favorite games of all time.
Short and sweet.
Just like me, too.
Ha ha.
Alright.
Let's see.
18.
How many do we have left then?
Uh...
11!
11 games left and I'll have completed...
50.
Whoa!
Come back to pink.
Thank you!
Pink for the sunset tan!
It was scary to lose the scarf in the snow, though not sure
taking clothes off would have held.
Thankfully the real scarf was you all along.
Thank you, Darko!
Thank you so much for the peek.
And yoo yoo yoo yoo yoo yoo yoo yoo yoo yoo!
Thanks for this astonishing and beautiful experience, Minky
and Cash Buddy Robot!
I've never played this game, but it did bring me beautiful
memories of Sky Children, and of the Light and Abzu.
Oh yeah, I might!
I might check out the other games by...
by this team, so...
I stretch I've been It's been a very busy day for me I woke
up And immediately started getting to work Not only on catch
up from stuff that I That I missed But like Lots of stuff
Lots and lots of planning still happenings For this week
Thanks for the stream It was a good distraction Thank you
Thank you Thank you
ketchup ketchup
but thank you guys so much for hanging out with me for this
short and sweet journey I had so much fun and it was very
satisfying and beautiful such a beautiful game oh that was
my controller disconnecting thanks for taking us on this
journey thank you thank you thank you yeah hmm So, um, I'll
head out now since I have a meeting or no, I'm meeting with
Vicky and Phoebe in 30 minutes, so I will go, I will go get
ready for that and thank you all for hanging out with me.
I had a lot of fun.
Um, uh, uh, did I post the schedule on YouTube?
well regardless I'll check but but lots of streams this week
I tried to since I was gone last week most of it and then
also I'll be gone for the next two weeks most of it and I
have some collabs this week I tried to like double up a
little bit extra to as much as I could So it's a pretty
packed week.
So lots and lots of streams.
Thanks for the streaming, Tomlondo.
Watching you play this beautiful game.
Andre goes, thank you.
Thank you, thank you.
Anyway, I'm going to head out now.
So take care.
I will see you when I see you next.
Bye-bye.
Bye-bye-bye.
Bye-bye-bye-bye-bye-bye-bye-bye-bye-bye-bye-bye-bye-bye-bye.
Bye-bye, bye-bye, bye-bye, bye-bye!
You know how I was like?
My screen protector is all full of scuffs now!
That drop really did a big scuff on my screen protector!
I think I'll have to replace it!
When I dropped my phone earlier!
Dang.
I guess better the screen protector than my own phone,
though, right?
you